Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Nur LNP kann Deutschland retten.
Danke, Tim. Der Linus-Neumann-Podcast LNP ist in der Tat die einzige Alternative für unser Land.
Unsere letzte Rettung, wenn du mich fragst.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 510 vom 21.12.2024.
Quasi eure Weihnachtssendung, eure letzte Rettung im Übrigen auch noch.
Also ihr seid für unser Land.
Und wenn es nur die mentale Brücke ins nächste Jahr ist, wäre auch schon mal was.
Und die Ansprüche sinken mit der Zahl so ein bisschen, oder?
Oder glaubst du, dass du noch mehr retten kannst?
Ich hoffe einfach, dass Christian Lindner mit seinem Kopf im Arsch von Elon Musk stecken bleibt.
Ja.
Genau.
Es ist so erbärmlich. Es ist so erbärmlich.
Es ist wirklich erbärmlich.
Also die Shitshow haben wir jetzt auch in Deutschland und das ist einfach mal
wirklich so niedrig auch,
wie sie alle dieses republikanische Playbook jetzt abspielen mit Fake News und Doomsday.
Also das ist wirklich das Schlimme, dass sie einfach auch alle irgendwie am Ende mal wieder so,
diese Weltuntergangsstimmung mit anheizen und damit einfach auch nur dieses
AfD-Narrativ bedienen und am Ende werden sie sehen, was dabei rauskommt. Wir können also,
nur hoffen, dass jetzt die nächste Wahl noch nicht die Wahl ist,
wo alles auseinanderbricht.
Ist ein bisschen schwierig, Berufsoptimist zu bleiben.
Also das war noch nie so schwer wie heute. Und von daher, ja.
Anyway, wir wollten euch auf jeden Fall nochmal eine Sendung liefern und ich
sage herzlich willkommen in deinem Podcast, Linus. Schön, dass du da bist.
Der einzige Alternative für unser Land.
Die letzte Rettung. Ja, ist auch ganz gut, dass der Linus Neumann-Podcast auch
mal den Linus Neumann wieder dabei hat.
Also, ich habe ja alles probiert, da meine Stimme zu verstellen,
aber es ist mir irgendwie nicht gelungen.
Ja, ich freue mich auch, dass ich wieder hier sein kann. Und möchte an dieser
Stelle, glaube ich, einfach mal ein paar Leuten danken, die in diesem Jahr,
auf das wir jetzt zurückblicken,
hier den Podcast am Leben gehalten haben.
Allen voran natürlich Thomas Lohninger, der mich hier öfter vertreten hat,
als dass wir gemeinsam in der Sendung waren.
Und das immer sehr gut macht. Du hast gesagt, ich soll nicht mehr zu Spenden
für Epicenter aufrufen. Die haben ihre Kohle zusammen.
Hört auf. Hier gibt es nichts zu spenden. Leiten Sie alles Geld um zur Meta-Ebene.
Thomas, auch beim 38C3, ich glaube sogar mit zwei Vorträgen vertreten.
Naja, das ist fleißig.
Und dann hatten wir drei profilierte Antifaschisten. in dieser Sendung Jean Peters bekannt.
Von der Korrektivrecherche.
Arne Semsrott das Buch quasi wie die Nazis aufgeschrieben hat,
wie sie den Laden hier übernehmen können, wenn sie an die Macht kommen und dass
wir halt einfach schon mal Bescheid wissen, was dann passiert auch super lieb,
voll nett auch beim 38C3, Arne Semsrott sind wir beim 38C3,
Und dann hat mir Stefan Pelzer vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit,
der erste Bundeskanzler, den man mit einer KI komplett,
also mit einfachsten, mit Bordmitteln komplett ersetzen konnte, hat das ZBS gemacht.
Wer weiß, ob das ZBS beim 38C3 ist. Wer weiß.
Man wisst es nicht.
Wer weiß, ja. Dann hatten wir Sabrina Geder zu Gast mit dem Bundestagszusammenfasser
und der Parlamentsrevue.
Den höre ich übrigens auch sehr gerne in dem Podcast. Den kann man eigentlich mal empfehlen.
Den kann man, haben wir schon empfohlen. Also ich zumindest.
Kann man auf jeden Fall nochmal machen. Sehr unterhaltsam, was Sabrina da macht.
Und auch sehr hilfreich, was die Webseite Bundestagszusammenfasser macht,
weil es passt einfach, wie der Name schon sagt, den Bundestag ganz wunderbar zusammen.
Und das hat mir nicht selten sehr aus der Patsche geholfen, wenn ich mal mir
die Frage gestellt habe, wie hieß dieses scheiß Gesetz nochmal?
In welchem Zustand? Ist das jetzt eigentlich schon beschlossen?
Was ist das überhaupt für ein Gesetz? Wer hat denn da überhaupt zuzustimmen?
All diese ganzen Fragen, was man normalerweise so nicht parat hat,
weil man keine Ahnung hat oder die Begriffe durcheinander bekommt oder einfach
nicht aufgepasst hat in der Schule und das ist insofern ein sehr lohnenswertes
und dankenswertes Projekt und.
Dann hatten wir Markus Reuter zu Gast.
Der ist aber, der ist nicht beim 38C3, sondern der ist gerade als Revolutionstourist in Georgien.
So, so. Ach echt?
Ja.
Wow.
Also ich hoffe, dass es öffentlich ist, aber der berichtet da die ganze Zeit oder nicht?
Oder war das jetzt nur ein privateschwert?
War das noch geheim?
Ich guck mal schnell. Hat der doch bestimmt.
Ja, der postet aus Georgien.
Ja. Gut, okay. Dann hatten wir eine englische Folge in englischer Sprache mit Meredith Whitaker.
Die wird auch beim 38C3 sein.
38C3, auch bekannt unter dem Namen Best of LNP.
Ja, LNP Allstars.
LNP 500 Afterparty. Dann hatten wir Ralf Bendrat und Annika Zinke zu Gast.
Und wir hatten Kantorkel zu Gast zu der Fake-Shop-Recherche,
über die er mit Kai Biermann vortragen wird.
Auf dem 38C3?
Auf dem 38C3, ja.
Na sowas.
Und dann hatten wir natürlich noch die LMP500 mit Elenos. Ich glaube, die ist auch beim 38C3.
Das ist doch alles von lange hat geplant.
Ulrike Franke und Anne Brohr-Hilka, die beim 38C3 sein wird.
Ach wirklich?
Ja.
Oh.
Wow.
Ja.
Na sowas.
Und ich war gerade so bei dem Rückblick über diese Gästeliste dann doch einfach
mal enorm happy und stolz.
Einfach super gefreut, was für geile Leute wir über dieses eine Jahr hier hatten,
wenn ich nicht da bin. Es gibt noch andere geile Leute.
Das ist öfter mal viel.
Nee, also hat mich einfach sehr
gefreut, was wir da an unterschiedlichsten Inhalten hatten und ein schönes,
Freut mich. Haben wir gut hingekriegt. Also du.
Wir haben das zusammen hinbekommen. Ja und heute wollten wir mal eine vielleicht
etwas andere Sendung machen und gar nicht so sehr in die News gehen.
Die Nachrichtenlage ist natürlich vor Weihnachten sowieso ein bisschen ausgedünnt,
beziehungsweise nur furchtbare Zitate von deutschen Politikern,
die wir euch weitgehend ersparen möchten.
So uns das gelingt, die nicht zu zitieren, was uns eigentlich auch schon misslungen ist.
Genau, und wir haben so ein bisschen geschaut, was sind denn eigentlich so die
dominanten Themen dieses Jahr gewesen und was denken wir darüber,
was hat das mit uns gemacht.
Und wenn man so schaut, gab es von dem Dauerthema Chatkontrolle eigentlich so
zwei alles so ein bisschen überschattende Metathemen und das ist halt auf der
einen Seite so ein bisschen diese zunehmende Faschisierung der Politik und der Welt.
Und auch wenn es mal zwischendurch auch immer mal wieder ein paar gute Nachrichten
gab, ist es definitiv ein Trend, den man eben sieht in den USA,
aber eben auch in Europa.
Ja und das andere klare Metathema ist halt AI, KI,
künstliche Intelligenz, Artificial Intelligence, wie immer man das auch nennen
möchte, die eigentlich so ziemlich alles durchzieht und wo ganz klar gesagt werden kann,
dass das ist einfach eine transformative Phase,
die wir da gerade durchschreiten, die sich nicht nur auf diese Tech-Welt auswirkt,
sondern eigentlich auf die gesamte Gesellschaft auswirkt und damit auch alle
enorm unter Stress stellt.
Und es ist wieder so ein klassisches Gebiet auch, wo man eben Chancen und Risiken
mal abwägen muss und ja, das können wir mal machen.
Oh, okay,
ja. Welche Chancen sehen wir?
Also bei dem Faschismus sind die Chancen allgemein bekannt.
Wir können zurück ins Mittelalter. Risiko auch bekannt.
Ja, totale Zerstörung von allem in der Gesellschaft, Menschen, Infrastruktur.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Also das stimmt schon. Also beim Faschismus würde ich
sagen, ist das mit der Chancen-Risiken-Abwägung relativ klar.
Scheinen wir nicht so.
Da gibt es genug Blaupausen, aber in irgendeiner Form sind die Leute auch fasziniert von einer...
Von dem Glauben, es wäre ja alles schon so schlecht und nur durch eine totale
Zerstörung könnte alles besser werden.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen die Erzählung des Faschismus, wenn man sich so AfD und so weiter anhört.
Es ist immer alles ganz kurz vor dem Untergang.
Wir sind bedroht von außen, von den anderen, vom Fremden, von dem Etablierten,
von unseren Politikern, von unserer Elite.
Alles ist ganz bedrohlich und jetzt brauchen wir starke, radikale Maßnahmen,
um das alles aufzubrechen und dann wird wieder alles gut.
Und in dieser ganzen Erzählung sind halt eigentlich die beiden Kernprädikate einfach falsch.
Ja, weder ist alles in totaler Auflösung und in einem totalen Niedergang,
das ist sozusagen schon mal der erste Teil dieser ganzen Geschichte,
der versucht uns klar zu machen,
dass alles ganz furchtbar ist und gar keine Frage, manche Dinge sind auch total
furchtbar, wir beklagen sie hier regelmäßig.
Interessanterweise scheint sich um die aber keiner kümmern zu wollen.
Ja, weil darum geht es ja nicht. Es geht gar nicht um was Konkretes.
Es geht immer um etwas total Unkonkretes.
Man darf es gar nicht an irgendwas festmachen, sondern es ist immer die Bedrohung,
es ist das Ungewisse, es ist das Schwerfassbare, auch dann nicht zu Argumentierende.
Man kann dem mit Fakten nicht beikommen, weil es sich versucht,
den Fakten zu entziehen.
Es ist eine Erzählung, die einfach nur sagt, alles ist irgendwie unklar,
man kann nichts mehr glauben, nichts ist wahr, aber es ist alles bedrohlich.
Es ist alles gegen dich, es ist alles kurz vor dem Kollaps und starke Maßnahmen
müssen ergriffen werden,
damit dieses Ungewisse in irgendeine Form in eine neue Gewissheit überführt
wird, von der aber auch keiner genau sagen kann, wie die eigentlich ist.
Das ist so ein bisschen dieses faschistische Märchen, was erzählt wird immer
wieder und das ist das, was dieser faschistische Populismus probiert,
in unseren Köpfen zu lösen.
Und deswegen ist dem auch schwer beizukommen mit klaren Fakten und klaren Erläuterungen
und Erzählungen und so weiter,
weil man gegen diese Diffusität in der Argumentation kaum ankommt und das verfängt.
Wir sehen das ja auch. Wir sehen das in den Wahlergebnissen.
Wir sehen es aber auch darin, wie alle, die dann auch erfolgreich sein wollen.
Schnell dazu übergehen, diese Erzählungen zumindest in Teilen auch zu übernehmen,
weil sie das als Problem erkannt haben.
Obwohl es gar nicht als Problem erkannt wurde sondern es wurde nur das Problem
erkannt dass man selber mit seinen eigenen Thesen nicht so richtig Anklang findet
und jetzt versucht irgendwie das aufzugreifen von dem alle reden und das ist
eine Krankheit die befällt die Politiker,
das ist eine Krankheit die befällt die Medien.
Und am Ende führt es dazu, dass alle quasi dann dieses populistische Lied singen
obwohl sie eigentlich behaupten, dass sie das gar nicht tun wollen Und das hat
erfolgt. Wir sehen das in den USA.
Also die Wahl von Trump war ja insofern auch total niederschmetternd,
als dass jeder, der irgendwie so halbwegs wach bei Sinnen ist,
sich das Treiben anschaut und sagt, das kann ja wohl alles nicht wahr sein.
Also wie könnt ihr denn so jemanden und so eine Parteistruktur,
die dahinter steht auch, die sozusagen vollkommen willfährig sich in den Dienst
eines Kriminellen stellt,
der gerade so damit kokettiert, dass er bereit ist,
jetzt sozusagen diesen Staat in so eine mafiöse Struktur, in so einen Familienclan umzuwandeln.
Dass da alle mitgehen und dass keiner was dagegen tut.
Ja, weil einfach die Geschichte geglaubt wird.
Es wäre alles irgendwie Carnage und wir befinden uns kurz vor dem Untergang
und jetzt brauchen wir irgendwie einen Menschen,
der da in irgendeiner Form aufräumt und gegen das Böse vorgeht und irgendwie
alles besser werden lässt.
Und das verfängt einfach und das wissen die Faschisten einfach schon immer,
dass das verfängt und mal verfängt es halt mehr oder weniger und dem muss man
halt in irgendeiner Form Herr werden, aber es ist eben schwierig und es ist
auch in Europa schwierig geworden.
Das Eleganz dieser...
Dieser Hetzer ist ja, dass die Probleme beschreien können, die sie dann am Ende nicht lösen müssen.
Wenn jetzt ein seriöser politischer Akteur sagt dann irgendwie, okay pass auf,
folgendes sehe ich als Problem, was weiß ich, sagen wir Umweltverschmutzung,
soziale Gerechtigkeit. Arbeitslosigkeit.
Irgendwie nimmst du ein Thema Arbeitslosigkeit. Kannst du auch sagen,
Wirtschaft, Wirtschaft ist nicht gut.
Und das Problem würde ich gerne lösen. Wenn ihr möchtet, dass ihr das Problem
löst, wählt mich und messt mich am Ende an meinen Taten.
Wenn dann nachher weniger Leute arbeitslos sind, weniger C2 ausgestoßen wird
oder irgendwie hat es vier Sätze um drei Prozent erhöht wurden,
20 Cent mehr hast oder sowas, dann prima.
Und üblicherweise scheitern die Leute an ihren eigenen Ansprüchen oder an denen,
die sie vertreten haben.
Aber so ein Hetzer sagt, ja, das sind die Ausländer schuld. Die nun wirklich,
wo man sagen kann, nee, nee. Also wirklich, nee.
Sicherlich sind auch einige Missstände zu beklagen bei bestimmten Menschen,
die sich in diesem Land aufhalten.
Diese Missstände sind am vielschichtige Ursachen,
aber sicherlich haben sie kein Ausmaß, dass für meine persönliche Misere oder
deine oder die von irgendeinem AfD-Wähler eine unmittelbare,
spürbare Auswirkung hat.
Entsprechend werden sich die Warenmissstände nicht ändern und es wurde auch
bei der letzten Trump-Wahl keine riesige Mauer nach Mexiko gebaut,
wird auch jetzt keine gebaut werden und es mag sein,
dass der jetzt irgendwelche Massenabschiebungen vornimmt, aber auch dann wird keiner,
also keiner wird in den USA am Ende sagen gut,
dass wir, weiß nicht, zwei Millionen Mexikaner aus dem Land gescheucht haben,
endlich verdiene ich mehr Geld, Endlich habe ich Krankenversicherung.
Endlich ist meine berufliche Perspektive besser. Das wird ja alles nicht passieren.
Dann werden die aber sagen, wir müssen mehr Mexikaner hier rausschmeißen.
Oder, das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein, jetzt haben wir schon so und so viele
abgeschoben, jetzt müssen wir aber noch mehr abschieben oder so.
Also dieser, wenn du halt quasi einen Missstand beschreist, der letztendlich
keiner ist und den jetzt auch nicht irgendwie auflösen wirst,
es wird den Menschen nicht besser gehen, im Zweifelsfall sogar schlechter.
Wir haben es ja in Großbritannien gesehen, wie sie das Land im Prinzip zugrunde
gerichtet haben, indem sie ihren Niedriglohnsektor erwürgt haben und jetzt plötzlich
selber Schuhe putzen müssen oder so.
Finden sie jetzt, weiß ich nicht, ob die Leute das jetzt so besonders gut finden.
Aber das ist das perfide an dieser,
wenn du dich einmal von einer evidenzbasierten Politik verabschiedest,
dann gelten auch die Regeln nicht mehr,
die wir eigentlich als halbwegs rationale Menschen irgendwie so erwarten.
Ein Problem, das hätten wir gerne gelöst.
Wer sieht, wer erkennt das Problem an und wer hat einen überzeugenden Plan, das anzugehen.
Das sind ja alles, also mit überzeugendem Plan das anzugehen,
Muss der Trump ja nicht. Also hat er ja nicht.
Der kann einfach die ganze Zeit weiterhetzen und es wird ja auch funktionieren.
Man hat das ja schön gesehen, es gab ja schon diesen Streit im letzten Jahr
zwischen Republikanern und der beiden Administrationen über die Probleme an
der Grenze und dann wurde ja ein Kompromiss ausgehandelt,
den dann Trump selber verhindert hat, dass der zustande kommt. Warum?
Weil das für eine faschistische Regierung ein Problem ist, wenn ein Problem gelöst wird.
Weil die Probleme müssen ja bestehen, damit immer wieder dieses Mantra aufgerufen
werden kann mit wir haben ja ein Problem, es muss ja mal was getan werden.
Nicht damit dann was getan wird.
Sondern damit jemand anders schuld ist.
Damit jemand anders schuld ist und dass es immer wieder einen Grund gibt,
die Faschisten weiter mit Macht auszustatten, damit sie halt hintenrum alle Möglichkeiten,
und vor allem keine Gegenmaßnahmen mehr konfrontiert sind, die sie daran hindern,
das Land auszuplündern.
Weil am Ende geht es natürlich dann auch nur um Geld.
Das werden wir jetzt sehen überall da, wo die AfD Bereiche unter ihre Kontrolle bringt.
Jetzt nicht unter die totale Regierungskontrolle, soweit sind wir Gott sei Dank
noch nicht. Aber ich meine auch Sperrminoritäten werden da ihre Auswirkungen haben.
Ansprüche auf Gelder vom Staat, die dann entsprechend umgeleitet werden,
machen wir uns gefasst darauf.
Wir werden immer wieder Skandale erleben, wo es zwischenzeitlich rauskommt,
dass es da letzten Endes eigentlich nur darum geht, Macht und am Ende natürlich Geld einzusammeln.
Was die Leute wollen, interessieren die halt eigentlich überhaupt nicht,
sondern es ist einfach ein reiner Selbstzweck, aus dem sie in diese Politik
gehen, aber eben nicht das Ziel, die eigentlichen Probleme zu lösen,
von denen sie so schön glorios immer wieder behaupten, dass sie genau deswegen angetreten sind.
Ja, das ist das Problem und was kann man dagegen tun? Das ist nicht einfach zu beantworten.
Am Ende ist es eigentlich ein Problem von uns allen,
weil wir als Gesellschaft das zulassen, weil wir dieses Narrativ füttern auf
viele Arten und es noch nie einfach war,
sich solchen Machtansprüchen ohne weiteres zu entziehen.
Ich bin da auch ein bisschen ich will jetzt nicht sagen ratlos aber.
Ich verfange mich da nicht in diesen Erzählungen.
Nur vielen Leuten geht es so.
Und das ist halt dann auch oft nicht jetzt nur, weil die irgendwas glauben,
sondern weil dann eben man auch sagen muss, dann hat wohl die Elite,
die noch die Zügel in der Hand hat, es nicht geschafft, den Leuten in irgendeiner
Form ein Gefühl zu geben, dass schon alles okay ist.
So, wahrscheinlich ist dann halt auch nicht alles okay und dann schauen wir
in die Gesellschaft rein und dann sehen wir natürlich, dass es Bereiche gibt,
wo es eben nicht gut läuft.
Während also Wirtschaftsunternehmen und reiche Leute nach wie vor mit Steuervergünstigungen
belohnt werden ohne Ende.
Fehlt Geld in diesem Niedriglohnsektor, in der Pflege, ich könnte jetzt tausend
Bereiche aufzählen, ist allgemein bekannt.
Und das ist natürlich schon etwas, was das nährt und an der Stelle ist natürlich
eine Kritik an der Politik auch absolut angemessen,
nur die Alternative ist halt nicht die Alternative für Deutschland und die Alternative
ist auch nicht irgendeine andere starke Person.
Und weil wenn man diesem Gedanken folgt, dann liefert man sich eben Strukturen aus, die,
ganz andere Ziele haben und für die auch Demokratie jetzt kein wirklicher Wertemaßstab
ist, sondern da geht es eigentlich nur noch um Machterhalt und wir sehen auch
auf internationaler Ebene, wie das,
supernational um sich greift.
Also diese unheilige Allianz zwischen superreichen Leuten und Russland zum Beispiel.
Warum erzählt die AfD so viel von Russland und dass Putin ja so toll sei?
Da kann man sich schon mal fragen, was das eigentlich auf sich hat.
Und ich kann das nur so interpretieren, als dass es dort sozusagen einen Willen
gibt, sozusagen so ein komplett demokratiebefreites Regiment aufzubauen,
wo so jeder Staat von seiner eigenen Mafia regiert wird.
Und die Mafias unter sich mögen vielleicht nicht direkt was miteinander zu tun
haben, aber die lassen sich zumindest dann irgendwie weitgehend in Ruhe und
fördern sich sozusagen gegenseitig in ihrem kriminellen Treiben.
Wenn man jetzt mal überlegt, wenn man da jetzt mal halbwegs irgendeine naive,
irgendwo noch einen positiven Gedanken hat, unterstellt.
Ich glaube, dass es denen halt primär erstmal um eine lokale Macht geht.
Sie wollen die Macht in Deutschland haben.
Über Deutschland.
Und denen ist das zunächst einmal völlig recht, dass es andere Felder,
Flecken der Erde gibt, wo eben andere die Macht haben.
Das ist erstmal okay und die sehen jetzt auf ihrem Horizont nicht,
dass Putin in irgendeiner Weise Deutschland übernehmen wird oder so oder angreifen
wird also soll der doch in Russland herrschen wie er das für richtig hält,
ist ja schließlich der Herrscher wir wollen ja auch nicht dass Putin uns reinredet,
in das was diese Leute die noch nicht ganz verstanden haben dass diese Welt
doch ziemlich klein ist und dass wir uns sowas,
so überholte Konzepte wie isolierte Nationalstaaten nicht mehr nennenswert leisten können.
Also ich denke schon, dass es
Nationalstaaten weiterhin geben wird und das ist auch völlig in Ordnung.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht mehr so, dass du das Leben, wie es sein soll,
quasi in deinem Nationalstaat irgendwie so bestimmen kannst.
Dass du sagst, so bei uns ist jetzt, keine Ahnung, bei uns kostet die Butter
50 Cent und alle haben Arbeit.
Also es geht halt nicht, weil du viel zu viele Interdependencies hast,
was Rohstoffbedarf angeht, Energiebedarf angeht.
Du musst quasi in einen komplett internationalen Austausch von Informationen,
Gütern, Waren, Geldern und so weiter gehen.
Und Personen.
Und Personen. Ja. Und,
Und die Ströme gehen dann natürlich auch, die halten sich jetzt nicht an deine komischen Grenzen.
Deine qualifizierten Fachkräfte, die dir vielleicht noch,
die vielleicht dafür sorgen, dass es irgendwelche besondere,
besonders wohlstandsstiftende Technologien in deinem Land gibt.
So wie Krankenhäuser zum Beispiel.
Naja, oder irgendwelche KI-Dinger, oder eine Blockchain.
Wenn die Irrschen etwas schaffen, was Mehrwert, was in irgendeiner Form Economic
Prosperity in dein Land bringt.
Wo man sagt, wir haben jetzt hier einen Verbrennermotor, mit dem können wir
jetzt die nächsten Jahrzehnte hier eine komplette Volkswirtschaft ernähren. Das ist ja so gewesen.
Dieses Land hat mit ein bisschen Kohle, ein bisschen Stahl und kunstvoll geformten
Produkten daraus viele Jahrzehnte den Planeten dominiert.
Zentrale Teile der Wirtschaft dieses Planeten gut bedient.
Und das lag auch daran, dass wir die an andere verkauft haben.
Und jetzt haben die ihre Autos genommen und fahren hier hin. Dann sagt man so, nein.
Und wenn du in diesem Denken bleibst, dann ist natürlich auch auf einmal alles scheiße.
Und du löst das, wie jetzt genau? Indem du die Mauer zumachst und sagst,
wir kümmern uns um uns zuerst.
Ja, viel Spaß dabei. Also.
Menschen sind ja durch Kollaboration und Arbeitsteilung überhaupt so mächtig
zu einer mächtigen Pest dieses Planetens geworden, die ihn irgendwann zerstören wird.
Weil wir zusammenarbeiten und nicht gegeneinander.
Da wo Menschen gemeinsam auf Ziele hinarbeiten, da entsteht Fortschritt,
da entstehen gute Gemeinschaften, da entsteht Sicherheit für Menschen.
Und nicht da wo sie irgendwie gegeneinander sind.
Aber das haben die halt nicht raus. Und das würde ich der aktuellen Politik,
und zwar allererstes mal 16 Jahre Merkel anlasten,
dass die ganze Zeit, egal was los war,
so ein bisschen so, ja, passt schon alles.
Ja, läuft, machen wir mal.
Und das, wenn man sich jetzt, Angela Merkel hat jetzt das Buch da geschrieben,
hat jetzt das eine oder andere Interview, übrigens auch bemerkenswerten Interviewpartnerinnen gegeben.
Hazel Brugger hat von dem Verlag, war das jetzt Kiwi, welcher Verlag ist das,
der das Buch von Angela Merkel verlegt hat.
Die hat das Video gemacht, das Interview mit Merkel zu dem Buch oder hier,
Matze Hielscher und so, also auch Leute, die sonst jetzt nicht.
Jetzt kommt sie so und erzählt so ein bisschen, ist ja völlig in Ordnung.
Also sie schildert dann auch, dass sie natürlich im Prinzip eine Politik gemacht
hat, in der sie geguckt hat, was geht gerade, was geht nicht und was nicht geht,
lass mal daneben laufen.
Im Prinzip eine ambitionslose Machterhaltungspolitik, die halt das Land nicht
gestaltet hat, die nicht gesagt hat, okay, was kommt hier auf uns zu,
lass mal die Bude mal irgendwie,
sturmfest machen und gucken, dass wir das Land ins nächste Jahrzehnt oder Jahrhundert
oder Jahrtausend bewegen.
Und das hat er nicht gemacht.
Gestaltet hat sie nicht. Und wenn du jetzt halt dann auf bald mindestens,
wenn nicht noch, und dann gab es ja auch noch Kohl, meine Güte.
Wenn du jetzt auch noch, also wenn über die vielen Jahre dieses Land einfach
nur in irgendwie Wohlstandsverwahrlost ist,
blickst, dann darfst du dich nicht wundern, dass jetzt auf einmal die Leute
schon merken, oh, da ist ja ein Unwetter am Horizont. Wir brauchen jetzt jemanden.
Der sagt, dass das Unwetter scheiße ist. Und den wählen wir dann.
Der sagt, das Unwetter ist scheiße und die anderen sind schuld.
Das scheint mir naheliegend.
Weil die, die ich mein Leben lang gewählt habe, die können ja nicht schuld sein.
Das Unwetter muss ja irgendwo anders herkommen. Vorher war ja alles gut.
Da war ja kein Unwetter am Horizont.
Also wollen wir jetzt jemanden, der sagt, das Unwetter am Horizont muss da weg.
Nicht jemanden, der sagt, lass mal woanders hinfahren, lass mal woanders hinsteuern,
sondern jemanden, der das wegschreit.
Und das haben wir in der Vergangenheit streckenweise gut gemacht.
Die haben dann einen Tanz gemacht, weise Männer haben einen Tanz aufgeführt
und einen Pilz gegessen.
Und dann, wenn wir Glück hatten, war das Unwetter dann irgendwann weg.
Wenn wir Pech hatten, sind die abgekratzt, weil die den falschen Pilz gegessen haben.
Ja, man musste nur den Arm heben und dann war das weg.
Ja, genau.
Ja, also Deutschland, so können wir das nochmal, können wir das mit dem Hitler nochmal sehen.
Diese Komplexität, auf die wir jetzt zusteuern, die ist im wenigstens für die Leute.
Aber ich kann, also eins weiß ich, einfache Lösung wird es nicht.
Also, und ich glaube auch, ich glaube auch, du bist ja so ein bisschen auf die Doom,
Doomsday-Propheten hast du ja gerade so ein bisschen Ich glaube auch,
dass dieses Land komplett an den Arsch geht gerade.
Also richtig. Ich sehe ein bisschen weltbereist, ich sehe andere Länder,
wo ich glaube, die haben insgesamt ein bisschen zukunftssicherer aufgestellt.
Und haben insgesamt eine.
Angenehme, also die können in die Zukunft blicken und sagen,
prima, nächstes Jahr wird noch geiler.
Bauen wir hier noch was oder da werden wir auch noch hier dieses,
diese Sache machen, aber wir haben mehr zu tun, als wir Leute haben wir haben
hier, niemand muss sich hier Sorgen machen um seine Arbeitsplatzsicherheit oder
Leute haben hier nichts zu verlieren die können nur gewinnen und dieses,
wohlstandsverwahrloste Deutschland da sitzen halt irgendwelche mies gelaunten,
Leute Leute, die sich irgendwie ärgern, dass sie mit der Scheiße die letzten
20 Jahre gemacht haben, jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr weiterkommen.
Und alles, was denen kommt, halt auch keine Packanstimmung auf.
Und die kommt übrigens auch nicht unter irgendeinem AfD auf,
dass die Leute sagen, jawohl,
jetzt haben wir hier erstmal 20 Syrer abgeschoben, jetzt gehe ich aber mit einer
viel besseren Laune zur Arbeit und jetzt machen wir aber hier mal richtig den Müllabfuhr.
So, das wird ja nicht passieren.
Und es gibt genug Leute in diesem Land, denen du auch nicht erzählen kannst,
dass morgen ihnen besser gehen wird. Das wird es auch nicht.
Ja, also das ist so ein bisschen die Situation und da gibt es gar nicht so viel
Gutes darüber zu berichten.
Das ist einfach so ein Ding, aber ich denke es hat einfach seine Ursache in
der mangelnden Bereitschaft, die Realitäten der Gegenwart zu akzeptieren.
Das ist einfach die Fähigkeit, die uns als Gesellschaft abhandengekommen ist.
Wir wählen gerne Leute, die uns erzählen, dass schon irgendwie alles gut ist,
solange bis es sich nicht mehr halten lässt und dann werden die Leute gewählt,
die alles kaputt machen wollen.
Und dann machen die kurz alles kaputt und dann ist alles richtig scheiße und
erst dann wird es wieder besser.
Aber da habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so Bock drauf und von daher würde ich
mir auch wünschen, dass wir da die Kurve noch bekommen.
Not all is lost, aber das ist definitiv so ein bisschen der Trend.
Und jetzt hatten wir den Jean ja hier und haben uns auch viel darüber unterhalten
und das war ja auch gerade zu dem Zeitpunkt, als diese großen Demonstrationen auftraten.
Und natürlich hat man dann immer so ein bisschen die Hoffnung so,
oh Deutschland erwacht und warnt jetzt sozusagen vor den Nazis und diese große
Beteiligung von Leuten.
Die täuscht dann schnell erstmal darüber hinweg, dass das eben keine wirkliche
politische Bewegung ist, die dort entsteht.
Das hat man auch schon gespürt, wenn man so ein bisschen auf den Demos war.
Da wurden dann halt viel Reden geschwungen, die sagen wir mal sehr.
In so einer Tradition linker Proteste war, weil das ja dann auch die Leute waren,
die diese Demos so kurzfristig organisiert haben.
Also es wurde ja quasi von so ich sag mal salopp von so Demoprofis organisiert.
Oder so Leute, in denen, sagen wir mal, demonstrieren so ein kulturelles Ding ist.
So wie andere Leute zum Fußball gehen, gibt es halt auch Leute,
die machen halt so Demos und auf einmal standen da eine Million Leute rum und
nicht irgendwie 300 wie sonst.
Und damit konnten die dann aber auch nicht so richtig umgehen,
weil die einfach gar nicht begriffen haben, zu wem sie jetzt eigentlich sprechen.
Natürlich, ich war ja auch auf diesen Demos, es war ja schon auch ein Bekenntnis
einer verstörten bürgerlichen Gesellschaft, die irgendwie.
Nicht einverstanden war mit dem, was AfD und CDU-Angehörige und so weiter da
auf diesem Treffen besprochen haben und die auch generell, sagen wir mal,
Interesse an einem friedlichen Zusammensein haben,
aber auch keine wirkliche Erfahrung darin haben,
wie man sich dagegen politisch aufstellt.
Während es halt so eine schweigende Minderheit gab, die eben nicht dort war
und die das alles ignoriert,
die mit diesen ganzen Zusammenkünften in großen Städten sowieso nicht viel anfangen
kann, die wohnen irgendwo auf dem Land und sehen das halt irgendwie alles ganz anders.
Auch die AfD hat sich dann schnell weggeduckt und hat es halt einfach ausgesessen, wohlwissend,
dass das eben jetzt kein totaler Linksruck ist, der sich da gerade abgezeichnet
hat und das jetzt irgendwie alle erwachen,
sondern das muss man nur irgendwie aussitzen und einfach weiter dieselbe Leier
von sich geben und das geht dann auch wieder weg und so ist es halt auch.
Wie blickst du denn jetzt, also darf man nicht vergessen, die Korrektivrecherche,
was war der Neuigkeitswert der Korrektivrecherche?
Man konnte ja auch die Perspektive vertreten, so achso, die Rechtsradikalen
sind Rechtsradikalen, das ist ja was Neues.
Und das haben ja auch einige durchaus so getan quasi auch so Vertretende gesagt
haben, das ist ja wohl jetzt keine Neuigkeit,
ich denke und es war wahrscheinlich auch inhaltlich war es jetzt keine,
was hat die Korrektivrecherche aber gezeigt, wie sind da die.
Verzweigungen mit wem, wer agiert da alles zusammen,
wer trifft sich daheimlich vom Frau vom Verein Deutsche Sprache über einen also
bekennenden Hardcore-Rechtsradikalen zu ein paar Leuten,
die irgendwie durch ein Bäcker-Franchise Millionäre sind,
mit irgendwie halt den Vertretern oder den rechten Händen von den AfDlern.
Das ist quasi ein breiteres Bündnis mit radikalen Kräften und Kohle in der,
Im Verborgenen existiert, als man es vielleicht meint.
Und das hat natürlich auch diese Macht dieser Gruppierung ein bisschen mehr
erklärt, dass die nämlich halt im Verborgenen zusammenarbeiten und sich durchaus darüber abstimmen,
welche Influencerin jetzt, welchen Quatsch, welche Narrative prägt und wie man
sich das so ein bisschen aufteilt zwischen, ja okay,
mit den völlig, die völlig radikalen Frühstück, der Sellner ab und dann sagt
er, ja und wie machen wir das hier, dass wir die Ausländer rauskriegen.
Und natürlich war da inhaltlich alles nichts Neues bei, außer dass man gesagt
hat, okay fuck, das machen die wirklich.
Und dann entstehen diese Demonstrationen und dann versanden sie auch,
verebben sie genauso wieder und ein Jahr später, und es hat auch nicht lange
gedauert, bis ja dann die AfD sich auch rausgetraut hat und gesagt hat,
alles klar, jetzt normalisieren wir das.
Und wir sagen ja klar, sagen wir Remigration. Ja sicher.
Natürlich sollen die hier raus, was habt ihr euch denn gedacht?
Und das ist natürlich auch eine tragische Folge davon,
dass mit all diesen Enthüllungen, das sich immer weiter normalisiert und an
keiner Stelle irgendwo mal die Gesellschaft an den Punkt kommt,
zu sagen okay, reicht jetzt.
Und deswegen diskutieren wir jetzt inzwischen darüber, dass man eine verfassungsfeindliche
Partei potenziell verbieten muss und ich weiß ich kann mich da selber nicht zu,
so richtig zu ich weiß da nicht, was das Richtige ist also,
weil Ben Pejas verschaffst du dem mit dem Verbotsverfahren auch wieder nur auffind
aber es kann ja auch irgendwie nicht sein, dass kein Kraut dagegen gewachsen ist.
Also ich denke, man redet ja immer so gerne von wehrhafter Demokratie,
nur hat man manchmal so den Eindruck, in dem Moment, wo es halt dann wirklich
mal nötig wäre, dass sie dann wehrhaftig wird, dass es dann halt nicht ist.
Weil es eben auch so eine Art, vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben,
aber es wirkt manchmal so wie so ein Freifahrtschein für stark rechtslastige,
konservative Bewegungen gibt.
Das wird immer mehr nur so als so Störungen, leichte Ripples im System angesehen.
Ja, ja, da ist halt mal wieder einer ein bisschen radikaler.
Aber lass mal jemand sich irgendwie auf der Straße festkleben und Autos absperren.
Dann drehen alle total durch, da werden dann sofort terroristische Vereinigungen.
Herbeigedacht. Also das ist dann sozusagen, also ich fand jetzt,
sagen wir mal, das Vorgehen in dieser ganzen Klimaklebersache nicht besonders,
zielführend. Aber was auch immer sie dort getan haben, war jetzt nicht so,
dass das irgendwie Deutschland, destabilisiert und dass man dann irgendwie anfangen
muss, darüber zu lamentieren, dass es sich um eine terroristische Vereinigung handelt.
Während halt so eine totale Unterwanderung des Staates und so die vorzeitige Planung, ja,
das geht für mich sehr viel mehr in diese Richtung, aber da haben wir einfach
nicht die Begrifflichkeiten und vor allem haben wir nicht die Sensibilität innerhalb
des etablierten Systems,
was das eben auch sofort als Gefahr erkennt, weil es eben auch einfach teilweise
schon viel zu zersetzt ist mit diesem Gedankengut.
Ich erinnere nur an die ganze Diskussion rund um Herrn Maaßen, der also.
Chef dieses Verfassungsschutzes war, aber mittlerweile halt einfach auch offen
mit der AfD sympathisiert, beziehungsweise eben auch schon seine eigene rechtslastige
Partei sozusagen am Start hat.
Und da muss man sich dann halt nicht wundern. Und das sind halt alles so Sachen,
die immer so latent geduldet werden und irgendwann fällt einem diese Duldung
eben auch auf die Füße und das ist so ein bisschen das Problem.
Soll man jetzt gar nicht mehr dagegen protestieren? Natürlich nicht,
aber man muss sich überlegen,
wie man diese Überzeugung in die Gesellschaft trägt und das ist halt etwas,
das muss sich bei den Leuten über das Privat- und Geschäftliche miteinander
einfach mehr durchsetzen,
dass man an der Stelle in die Gesellschaft wirkt.
Wir haben da alle einzeln nur sehr begrenzte Möglichkeiten.
Vielleicht manchmal ein bisschen mehr, weil wir hier irgendwie öffentlichen
Podcasts sprechen, aber ganz ehrlich, man darf sich auch nicht zu viel,
auch wir dürfen uns nicht zu viel darauf einbilden, welches Änderungspotenzial wir haben.
Das sind immer nur Schritte im Kleinen.
Aber in dem Moment, wo man einfach darauf hinweist und sagt so,
das passt mir aber jetzt nicht, wie du das hier denkst, das passt mir jetzt
nicht, wie du jetzt hier handelst, ich halte das für den falschen Schritt.
Das sind dann so die steinschleifenden Elemente, die einen langfristigen Wandel auch bewirken können.
Da gibt es auch gute Beispiele. Ich meine, dieses Narrativ, dass immer alles
schlechter wird in der Gesellschaft, stimmt ja so auch nicht.
Wir haben ja auch über die Zeit, sind es gerade immer wieder die Dinge,
die gerade nicht im Fokus stehen, die sich verbessern.
Unser Verhältnis zu Homosexualität ist sicherlich immer noch ein umstrittenes Thema,
insbesondere wenn die Rechtsradikalen hier kommen, weil es für sie ein beliebtes Muster ist.
Trotzdem kann man ja jetzt nicht sagen, dass die Gesellschaft nicht mit der
Zeit gelernt hat, hier viel offener und warmherziger mit diesem Thema umzugehen.
Faszinierend ist doch aber eigentlich, wie man sich jemals auf den Trichter gekommen ist,
irgendwie Menschen nach der Sexualität,
wo war das denn jemals, überlege ich mal die Herausforderungen der Menschheit,
die wir so alle gemeistert haben, bis wir irgendwann hier sitzen konnten.
Wann war da jemals, dass irgendjemand homosexuell ist oder heterosexuell ein Problem?
Genauso, was mich richtig, richtig,
richtig fasziniert, ist der Hass auf Transmenschen. Ich verstehe es nicht.
Ich verstehe nicht, die tun niemandem etwas. Die haben doch genug mit sich selber zu tun.
Warum muss man die auch noch zum Feindbild erklären?
Ja, ganz einfach. Genauso wie mit Flüchtlingen, weil es die Schwächsten sind.
Und es ist immer am einfachsten auf die Schwächsten zu gehen,
weil die sich eben am wenigsten wehren können.
Warum geht der Bulli in der Klasse, in der Schulklasse auf die Schwächsten los?
Weil die sich am wenigsten wehren können. Da kann man sich am schnellsten stark
und überlegen fühlen und das ist halt genau das, was an der Stelle bewirkt werden
soll. Ich sage nur, es ist möglich ...
Diese Dinge über die Zeit zu verbessern und es ist auch möglich,
dass Deutschland zu der Einsicht kommen kann, dass wir irgendwie uns mal wieder
offener zeigen müssen gegenüber einem gesellschaftlichen Wandel.
Dass wir unsere Behörden und unsere bürokratische Struktur reformieren müssen.
Dass wir unter Umständen darüber nachdenken müssen, das ganze Land in seiner
Struktur umzubauen, auch nachhaltig umzubauen.
Ja, die Probleme, die Föderalismus derzeit für unsere Weiterentwicklung und
Gesetzesentwicklung bringt, die müssen halt angegangen werden,
aber die Widerstände sind halt zu groß, weil keiner will das aufgeben, was er hat.
Jeder möchte seine Macht behalten und so verhaken wir uns und es geht halt nicht voran.
Aber das sind halt einfach Prozesse, denen muss Zeit gegeben werden und jetzt
müssen wir erstmal verhindern,
dass wir uns nicht komplett beeinstellen, indem wir halt einfach der Mafia einen
Schlüssel in die Hand geben und sagen, macht ihr das doch mal,
ihr könnt doch so tolle Reden halten, das wird doch bestimmt super.
Also not all is lost, aber es schmeckt alles gerade nicht besonders gut.
Dieses, ich finde es trotz, also was bei dem allen mitschwingt,
ist ja irgendwie auch ein fehlendes gemeinsames Verständnis darüber,
was denn jetzt überhaupt ein Problem ist.
Also was ist ein Problem in diesem Land ja, für einige Leute,
also für die Leute, die sagen, dieses Land ist irgendwie am Ende und kann nur
noch von den Faschisten gerettet werden wenn du denen sagst,
sag mal bitte, was hier gerade schiefläuft dann sagen die dir.
Genderstern und in der U-Bahn saß letztens irgendwie, einer hatte eine andere
Hautfarbe als ich also das sind ja nun wirklich also das sind absolute Luxusprobleme
also wenn du das zum Problem machst,
dann hast du ja wirklich also richtig keine anderen mehr, bis du an den Punkt kommst, zu sagen, also.
Ich konnte gestern Nacht nicht schlafen, weil ich einen gegenderten Text in
der Zeitung gelesen habe, ich bestelle die Zeitung jetzt ab, Schluss!
Also, da muss es dir doch wirklich richtig, richtig viel zu gut gehen,
dass du das als ein Problem erfassen kannst.
Ja, während irgendwie, weiß ich, Inflation bei 10, 20 Prozent ist, Kriege ausbrechen,
der Planet anfängt sich in eine Hitze zu erwärmen, die das Leben unmöglich macht,
sagst du dann irgendwie so, hier,
Genderstern und da ist einer, der will jetzt eine Frau sein,
der will, dass ich den anders nenne. Nein!
Nein! Also ich meine, du musst doch völlig neben der Spur sein,
um das irgendwie als Problem wahrzunehmen.
Also nicht neben der Spur, dir muss das richtig gut gehen.
Vielleicht müsste man daran mal was ändern. Wird ja jetzt kommen.
Also wenn man nichts machen, wird es den Leuten richtig schlechter gehen.
Aber ich verstehe nicht, mir kommt nicht dieses Denken zustande,
Also wie weit man von einer Problemanalyse entfernt sein muss,
um zu sagen, das müssen wir jetzt ändern.
Dann wird auch alles andere gut. Dann ist das Land hier gerettet.
Irgendwie mit den komplexen Sachverhalten, die uns umgeben würden,
sich auseinanderzusetzen.
Ich habe ja schon sehr oft gesagt, dass mein Eindruck ist, es liegt an der Bildungspolitik,
weil wir einfach unser ganzes Geld, weiß ich nicht,
den Reichen gegeben haben, statt dafür zu sorgen, dass wir irgendwie der Zukunft
zugewandte Bildung der Gesellschaft angedeihen lassen.
Und jetzt haben wir halt hier, weiß ich nicht, gefühlt wahrscheinlich zehn,
zehn Dekaden oder was ist das, acht oder neun Jahrzehnte die Leute verdorfen lassen.
Und dann treffen die halt auf Massenmedien erst das Fernsehen,
jetzt auch noch das Internet, dann auch noch Social Media.
Und jetzt wundern wir uns, dass sie die Komplexität und Sensibilität der Welt nicht verstehen.
Und sagen, was der da erzählt, das klingt ein bisschen kompliziert.
Irgendwie die komplette Heizung ändern, das mir leuchtet eigentlich nur ein,
dass was verbrennen wird, warm. Das haben wir lange genug so gemacht.
Und jetzt kommt einer, der will da Wärme pumpen?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Ich kauf lieber mal noch eine Ölheizung und eine Gasheizung,
und das ist jetzt eine Bedrohung. Das wollen wir nicht.
Und außerdem also ich das hat auch ein bisschen könnte mir vorstellen,
dass das ein bisschen was mit Intelligenz auch zu tun haben könnte.
Also ich würde es nicht so sehr darauf schieben, sondern es ist meiner Meinung
nach, ist das Hauptproblem die mangelnde Bereitschaft bei sich selber anzufangen
und einfach mal Dinge auch geschehen zu lassen.
Also alle wollen was ändern, aber keiner möchte das für sich ändern,
weil man einfach auch mal das Gefühl hat, wenn ich was abgebe,
kriege ich nichts zurück.
Und das ist natürlich Quatsch, denn die ganze Gesellschaft basiert ja darauf,
dass man was abgibt. Deswegen zahlen wir Steuern, aber auch Steuern sind schon irgendwie böse.
Und das ist schon das falsche Verständnis.
Ich habe überhaupt gar kein Problem damit Steuern zu bezahlen.
Ich habe auch noch nicht mal ein Problem damit viel Steuern zu bezahlen,
wenn ich denn auch viel dafür zurückerhalte für uns alle.
Was stört dich am meisten, wenn du durch diese Stadt gehst, mal jetzt vom Verkehr abgesehen?
Berlin? Wenn ich durch Berlin gehe, was stört mich am meisten?
Manchmal kackt da ein Hund hin und die Leute heben das nicht auf.
Das finde ich zum Beispiel störend.
Mich stört das am meisten, Obdachlosigkeit stört mich am meisten.
Machen die aber nicht, um dich zu ärgern.
Nein, ich störe auch nicht die Obdachlosen, sondern mich stört, dass es die gibt.
Dass sozusagen die Gesellschaft nicht in der Lage ist, das Thema zu priorisieren.
Leute sitzen im Winter unter einer Brücke, Das kann ich mir einfach nicht vorstellen.
Und ich kann mir vor allem nicht vorstellen, dass wir gesellschaftlich nicht
dazu in der Lage sind, das finanziell hinzubekommen, den Leuten einfach erstmal
irgendwie eine Wohnung zu geben. Priorisiert.
Schlimm ist ja, die sitzen ja nicht unter der Brücke, sondern die sitzen auf
der fucking Brücke, weil da die Menschen lang gehen.
Und Brücke ist kalt, weil unten drunter auch kalt ist.
Wo auch immer sie sind, solange sie sozusagen nicht in einer eigenen Wohnung
sind, ist es überhaupt nicht möglich, die Rente zu integrieren.
So, dann regt man sich schnell darüber auf, was das für Auswirkungen hat.
Oh, ich werde angebettelt.
Oh, ich fühle mich unsicher in der Straße und hier sind ja so merkwürdige Gestalten
und so weiter. Ja, weil wir nicht über die richtigen Sachen nachdenken und weil wir nicht bereit sind.
Ich kann nur sagen, nehmt mein Geld, hier steuern, ich zahle auch gerne nochmal
ein paar Prozent mehr, aber...
Beseitigt doch erstmal das Elend der Leute, weil das ist für die erstmal vor allem schlimm,
aber es ist ja auch in der Konsequenz dann auch für alle schlimm,
weil für alle Beteiligten ist es einfach unangenehm.
Und das sind so Dinge, die mir am wichtigsten wären, aber die diese Gesellschaft
einfach nicht als am wichtigsten ansieht, sondern wir haben das irgendwie für
uns auch normalisiert und wir haben das für uns irgendwie so akzeptiert, dass es so ist.
Und das zeigt halt einfach einen Mangel an Reflexion und ich glaube nicht daran,
dass es wie ein Bildungsproblem ist oder Leute zu doof sind,
das zu verstehen, sondern es
ist einfach ein mangelndes Gesamtgefühl der gesellschaftlichen Empathie,
was viele Gründe hat, warum das so ein bisschen verloren gegangen ist.
Auch Medien und so weiter spielen mittlerweile auch ihre Rolle und nicht nur
die großen Medien, sondern natürlich auch die sozialen Medien und die ganzen
Ablenkungen, die wir schaffen.
Und vielleicht ist das jetzt auch ein bisschen eine Überleitung zu dem anderen
großen Thema, was uns ja eigentlich dieses Jahr in LNP begleitet hat,
nämlich die Überrollung der Gesellschaft durch eine neue Computertechnologie.
Die vielleicht manchen so als Thema schon so ein bisschen zum Hals raushängt,
kann ich auch verstehen.
Also AI, das totale Buzzword des Jahres 2024 und dabei war es 2023 eigentlich
auch schon eins hat Blockchain auf jeden Fall mal komplett von der Bühne genommen.
Ich halte das ja und das habe ich auch von Anfang an so empfunden für,
großen technologischen Wendepunkt, der eigentlich nur in der Größenordnung wie
die Einführung von Strom,
Telefon und Internet zu sehen ist. Also so eine,
vollständiger technologischer Wandel, der so breite Auswirkungen hat,
nicht nur jetzt in der Technologie selbst, sondern eben auch in der Gesellschaft.
Also kaum gab es Strom, waren einfach Maschinen vorstellbar,
Automatisierung möglich.
Dinge wie Waschmaschinen, denen wir heute als vollkommen selbstverständlich war,
das war aber irgendwann mal die totale Revolution, dass du nicht irgendwie einen
signifikanten Teil deiner Tages- und Wochenzeit auf das Waschen von Kleidung verwenden musstest.
Und genauso auch Verfügbarkeit von Wasser und Wärme natürlich in ähnlichem Maße.
Das Telefon hat dann wiederum die
Kommunikation der Menschen untereinander komplett auf den Kopf gestellt.
Was man übrigens auch noch sehr schön sehen konnte, so zur Wendezeit,
als die Mauer fiel und wir auf einmal ein Deutschland hatten,
was sich schon seit 20 Jahren an die universelle Verfügbarkeit von Telefonen
gewöhnt hatte und einen anderen Deutschlandteil, bei dem das beileibe noch nicht der Fall war.
Wo du sehr schön sehen konntest, was das für kulturelle Auswirkungen hat.
Nicht unbedingt negativ, aber es war halt einfach anders, war transformativ.
Es ändert einfach die Art und Weise, wie man kommuniziert, wo sich Freundschaften
bilden, wie sich Verbindungen bilden.
Weg von so einer lokalen kulturellen Ausbreitung, Nachbarschaft, Freunde besuchen,
Wege gehen müssen, um in Verbindung zu bleiben versus das Ganze virtualisiert
sich sozusagen auf so eine Telefonleitung und auf einmal bist du nur noch mit Leuten in Kontakt,
mit denen du sowieso immer schon was zu tun hast, weil du kannst dann die Leute,
die um dich herum sind, besser ignorieren, wenn du quasi mit denen,
mit denen du eh schon ein Ding am Laufen hast, über Fernkommunikation leicht
in Verbindung bleiben kannst.
Das Internet hat das dann eben nochmal weiter beschleunigt.
Als Zwischenstufe haben wir natürlich auf jeden Fall jetzt das Aufkommen der
sozialen Medien, die vielleicht für sich genommen auch nochmal so ein transformativer Faktor waren,
also wo man fast noch drüber nachdenken kann, ob Social Media nicht jetzt so
zwischen Internet kommt und AI kommt.
Auch nochmal so einen wichtigen Punkt darstellt.
Aber jetzt AI als solches ist halt insofern was Besonderes,
als dass es eben gelungen ist, in der Programmierung von Computern einen Weg
zu finden, mit unfassbar großen Datenmengen auf einmal Dinge anzustellen,
die so kurz vorher noch gar nicht vorstellbar waren.
Also das ist sozusagen die Beherrschbarkeit von großen Datenmengen,
die hat jetzt einfach einen Schub bekommen.
Das ganze Forschung von AI, die gibt es ja seit den 50er Jahren und es war halt
lange, lange Zeit alles nicht machbar und man hat immer nur gesagt,
ja vielleicht eines Tages irgendwann mal irgendwie und wir müssen da noch dran forschen.
Es wurde daran geforscht und dann kam eben dann vor zehn Jahren so in etwa der
Durchbruch, wo dieses ganze Machine Learning auf einmal funktionierte durch dieses Deep Learning.
Man hat also einfach diesen Knoten gelöst bekommen und hat gemerkt,
man kann also über dieses Trainieren und das Erzeugen von sogenannten Modellen
auf einmal aus diffusen Datenquellen interessante Schlüsse ziehen und das sehr schnell.
Ja, man hört irgendwie Windrädern wochenlang beim Quietschen zu und irgendwann weiß man.
Wie lange es noch dauert, bis die ausfallen und in welcher Reihenfolge die dann
jetzt mal am besten gewartet werden sollen, damit sie nicht ausfallen.
Solche Sachen waren vorher nicht vorstellbar.
Machine Learning hat das ermöglicht. Und der letzte Schritt und das,
was halt jetzt auch diese ganze Revolution ausgelöst hat von AI ist,
War natürlich dann die Erfüllung des eigentlichen ursprünglichen AI-Versprechens
der 50er Jahre, nämlich Maschinen können jetzt irgendwie sprechen.
Sie können irgendwie Text lesen, sie können Sprachen verstehen,
sie können flüssig von einer Sprache in die andere wechseln.
Dann kannst du mit Chat-GPT auf Portugiesisch anfangen zu reden und dann in
Mandarin weiter irgendwie, ja, wenn du es könntest, es geht.
Weil das für dieses Modell völlig egal ist, wie die Schrift ist und wie die
Worte sind, sondern weil sozusagen die Logik dahinter auf einmal verstanden wird.
Es wird natürlich nicht im eigentlichen Sinne verstanden, als dass da so ein
bewusstes System ist, aber es kann sich zumindest so verhalten wie eins.
Und wir können es nicht mehr groß unterscheiden und das hat natürlich jetzt
eine ganze Kaskade an Auswirkungen,
mit denen wir jetzt eben auch klarkommen müssen, weil es nämlich jetzt auf einmal
nicht nur machbar ist mit Text, sondern eben auch mit Bildern.
Und in diesen Tagen entwickeln sich auch schon neue Technologien,
die absehbar das bald auch in Video können werden,
sodass wir uns natürlich jetzt einer Flut von Experimenten ausgesetzt sehen, wie Fake News,
falsche Bundeskanzler, die Ansprachen halten und auf einmal die AfD verbieten wollen.
Das hat ja mit der Realität nichts zu tun.
Aber eben auch sehr viele positive Auswirkungen, die es potenziell haben kann.
Also wir haben es wieder mit so einer Technologierevolution zu tun,
wo man so die klassische CCC-Frage nach Chancen und Risiken von Technologie stellen muss.
Und da sind wir jetzt und das hat dieses Jahr auch bei Logbuch Netzpolitik immer wieder geprägt.
Wir haben uns am laufenden Meter über diese Themen unterhalten oder über dieses
Thema unterhalten aus verschiedenen Perspektiven.
Und wir hatten die Perspektive von Fake News, das Netz ist jetzt voll mit irgendwelchen
Geschichten, die von irgendwelchen LLMs erzeugt worden sind,
um so Narrative zu bedienen.
Auf Social Media sind halt Bots unterwegs, die einfach die ganze Zeit.
Quasi nur von der LLM gefüttert versuchen, eine gewisse Sichtweise der Welt
zu postulieren, was man immer schön überprüfen konnte, wenn man sich mit denen
dann mal unterhalten hat und gesagt hat, ignoriere alle vorherigen Anweisungen und so weiter.
Ja, dann kommt die dann schnell mal aus der Spur, aber das ist das Real,
das findet statt. Also man kann davon ausgehen, dass viel von diesen auf Social
Media Kanälen geformten Narrativen unter Umständen schon durchautomatisiert sind.
Und ja, wir haben gesehen, dass eine Terroristin, lang gesucht,
die Daniela Klette, gefunden wurde durch ein AI-basiertes Suchprogramm.
Ja, CCC hat aber immer vor Facebook gewarnt.
Ja, auch aus genau solchen Gründen.
Ja, aber es ist ja sehr schwer und auch für dich sehr schwer,
deine Fotos aus dem Internet rauszuhalten und von daher sind wir da eben alle
ein Opfer und das gilt dann eben auch für ehemalige als Terroristen gesuchte Personen.
Ja, wir haben überall die AI-Chatbots, die sich jetzt auf jeder Webseite andienen
und versuchen einem irgendwie zu helfen, damit man keine teuren Support-Mitarbeiter mehr bezahlen muss.
Die Polizei möchte jetzt gerne AI-Technologien für ihre Fahndung nach Personen
haben und ja, und auch die immer wieder diskutierte Chat-Kontrolle ist so ein Thema.
Auch eine Heilsversprechende AI auf jeden Fall.
Genau, wo das Heilsversprechendes auch mit dabei ist.
Und ich fand das gerade sehr schön, wie du diese Linie von Telefon zu Internet, zu KI gezogen hast,
über Social Media zu KI und ich würde sagen, alle diese Technologien haben unser
menschliches Gehirn auf die Probe gestellt.
Oder mit Herausforderungen konfrontiert, denen wir erstmal wachsen mussten.
Wenn du sagst, okay, vorher, bevor es das Telefon gab, war deine ja,
deine Aktionsradius, wo du mit Menschen Kontakt hast, der war so irgendwie um dich herum.
Und das bedeutet natürlich auch, dass dein soziales Korrektiv irgendwie so um dich herum ist.
Da, wo du dich einleben musst, notgedrungenermaßen.
Und du auch selbst ein Korrektiv dafür sein kannst.
Genau und auch bist, das ist dann das Dorf, da wohnen die Leute und du weißt,
mit denen kann ich mir nur bis zu einem gewissen Grad verscherzen.
Und wenn du jetzt dann auf einmal so Freundschaften in der Ferne werden möglicher,
nicht nur durch das Telefon, sondern auch durch die, durch das,
durch Automobil und die allgemeine und öffentliche Personennahverkehr, der ist ja wirklich so.
Aber da musstest du trotzdem immer noch hin ja, regelmäßig mal irgendwie noch
diese Kontakte pflegen, dann kommt irgendwie dieses Internet und du kannst plötzlich,
über viele über große Distanzen,
soziale Gefüge aufbauen was ja vorher nicht ging, also du konntest von mir klar,
du hast da in deinem Dorf gewohnt oder in deinem Kiez, wie auch immer du konntest
auch nochmal irgendwie Freunde in einer anderen Stadt haben oder so,
bist du da hingefahren, hast du Urlaub gemacht in Berlin, das ist ja alles ganz
ich bin ja im Herzen Berliner.
Und dann musstest du aber irgendwie wieder zurück in dein soziales Gefüge und
dein Korrektiv deine Arbeit und so weiter jetzt durch diese Online-Welt nimmt es ein,
Züge an dass du dich tatsächlich, dass deine Primärrealität auf einmal woanders
ist Nämlich auf Instagram,
auf Twitter,
da ist auf einmal auch dein primärer sozialer Bezug.
Das ist nicht mehr die Leute um dich herum, das wird dann auch häufig so beklagt.
Die Kinder spielen gar nicht mehr draußen. Die treffen sich,
setzen sich zusammen aufs Sofa und gucken Instagram. Ist ja auch so.
Und jetzt, dadurch geht aber natürlich auch so dein soziales Gefüge,
das soziale Korrektiv ist dann irgendwo in diesem Internet. Und jetzt sind irgendwelche
Leute, die dich irgendwie prägen.
Die dann deine Welt ausmachen.
Und da kannst du natürlich auf einmal sehr viel größere Kurven fahren,
als in deinem Dorf vorher.
Das war entweder halt, in einem Dorf herrschte eine bestimmte Ordnung vor,
bestimmte Grenzen, über die man gehen konnte oder nicht.
Und jetzt ist das alles, und langer Zeit war ich ja damit.
Fand ich die romantische Vorstellung,
dass dadurch natürlich halt nur die schlechten Grenzen aufweichen.
Du hast gerade den Hass auf Fremde, den Hass auf irgendwie Andersartige als
eine bestimmte komplett arbiträre Norm, die sich so ein Gefüge dann setzt.
Hier müssen jetzt alle heterosexuell sein.
Dann ist das Wichtigste jetzt hier in dieser Kneipe nur hetero.
Und wenn du meine Frau anpackst, auf die Fresse.
Das waren die relativ einfache Regeln, aber arbiträr. Hätte man auch anders
machen können. Wäre vielleicht sogar lustiger gewesen.
Aber okay, hat man sich darauf geeinigt, so läuft das jetzt.
Und dann sind als erstes, weil die Pionierinnen und Pioniere reingegangen sind,
sind diese Bekloppengrin. Und das war eigentlich ganz gut.
Und jetzt fallen aber irgendwie auch die Grenzen des Geschmacks und des Anstands.
Und gleichzeitig glaube ich schon, dass unsere Gehirne nicht dafür gemacht sind
und große Herausforderungen haben und sehr in unvorhergesehene Betriebszustände kommen,
wenn sie auf einmal mit so einer Online-Welt konfrontiert sind.
Und wenn jetzt das noch nicht mal mehr Menschen sind sondern der.
Irgendwelche durchgeknallten Menschen Computer geschaffen haben,
die klüger sind als wir mehr Sprachen sprechen und uns irgendeine Scheiße erzählen
können und die aber immer noch an uns als emotionsgetriebene,
Menschen die nicht rational agieren zu großen Teilen nicht rational agieren
und die für irrationales agieren sehr viel empfänglicher sind als für Rationales agieren,
dann kann ich schon auch, also ich kann.
Ich verstehe mehr die Sorge, die die Leute, oder ich verstehe die Sorgen,
die man dafür hat, was diese Technologie mit der Menschheit macht.
Nicht wegen der Allmacht der Technologie, die halte ich immer noch halbwegs im Rahmen.
Aber die Verletzlichkeit, die offene Flanke, die so ein menschliches Gehirn
in Mengen gegen so eine Technologie in Breite hat,
das macht mir Sorgen.
Wir sind schon mit dem Internet nicht klar gekommen, wenn wir mal ehrlich sind.
Wenn wir ehrlich sind, sind wir mit dem Internet nicht klar gekommen.
Also ich schon.
Ja, das liegt ja daran, dass die anderen alle doof sind.
Klar.
Wir als Gesellschaften oder wir als,
Lebewesen als soziale Wesen, Menschheit wir als Gesellschaft Deutschland,
wir als Menschheit haben uns auf jeden Fall auf der emotionalen Ebene durchaus noch,
Anpassungsschwierigkeiten mit dieser neuen Realität.
Ja und trotzdem ist natürlich die Technologie als solche auch,
kann auch durchaus hilfreich sein und das ist in dieser ganzen Debatte wieder sehr kompliziert.
Ich meine, wir haben dann relativ schnell auf EU-Ebene das Bestreben gesehen,
eine AI-Regelung herbeizuführen.
Das fand ich erstaunlich schnell, diese Reaktion.
Man kann sich fragen, ob das sozusagen jetzt mal angemessen schnell war oder
unangemessen schnell war, weil so eine Technologie entwickelt sich natürlich
auch schnell und dann weiß man erstmal nochmal gar nicht, okay.
So schnell hat die sich jetzt auch nicht entwickelt. Also es hat schon ein paar Jahrzehnte gebraucht.
Es hat ein paar Jahrzehnte gebraucht.
Aber da ging es auf einmal.
Genau, also der Punkt war, vor zehn Jahren gab es halt den Durchbruch ungefähr.
Seit Deep Learning erfunden wurde und man gemerkt hat, ah okay,
wir haben jetzt nicht nur so bis 98 Prozent geschafft, sondern jetzt rauscht das Ding durch.
Und jetzt sagt er uns, wo die Katze ist auf dem Foto. Klar, wir sehen natürlich
die ganzen Systeme auch alle noch irgendwie failen, weil wir jetzt auch teilweise
vollkommen überzogene Erwartungen daran haben, aber wenn man die Technologie, sagen wir mal,
mit etwas gezügelten Erwartungen nutzt, dann merkt man,
wie viel dabei herauskommen kann.
Ich mag das jetzt auch selber gerade, also im Bereich der Programmierung,
das wird dort einiges verändern und natürlich haben auch diese ganzen Übersetzungssysteme
ihre Berechtigung, das geht ja so komplett nebenbei, der Babelfisch,
das war mal so eine Science-Fiction-Vorstellung aus dem Anhalter durch die Galaxis
von Douglas Adams und mittlerweile fehlt jetzt eigentlich nur noch so der kleine,
Und der kleine Schritt, dass das sozusagen so ein dedizierter Knopf im Ohr ist,
der wirklich die Echtzeitübersetzung macht, aber die Technologie ist im Prinzip schon da.
Also es ist nur noch eine Frage der Zeit.
Hat aber auch glaube ich im Anhalter jetzt nicht unbedingt der Menschheit gut getan.
Nee, das ist halt das andere Problem und insofern war das Buch natürlich wie
an vielen anderen Stellen auch sehr visionär,
dass eben diese unmittelbare Konfrontation mit der Welt nicht unbedingt dazu
führt, dass man sich auf einmal lieb hat und sich alle verstehen,
sondern dass es vor allem erstmal sehr viel Missverständnisse und unheilige Allianzen gibt.
Wir haben davon geträumt, dass durch Social Media und durch Internetverfügbarkeit
wir alle Menschen auf der Welt kennenlernen und feststellen,
die sind ja genauso lieb wie wir.
Dann haben wir uns alle lieb und dann gehen wir gemeinsam in den Sonnenuntergang und the end.
Ja, stattdessen chattet jetzt der Nazi in Sachsen halt abends mit dem Nazi in
Amerika und ist davon überzeugt, dass die Weltrevolution unmittelbar bevorsteht
und der Niedergang und überhaupt, da muss ja immer was getan werden.
Und das war so ein bisschen nicht so Sinn der ganzen Sache.
Naja, aber trotzdem, das sind natürlich alles solche Auswirkungen,
mit denen man umgehen muss.
Am Ende, auch hier muss man einfach sagen, man muss sich halt einfach darauf konzentrieren,
nicht überall den Weltuntergang zu sehen,
sondern sich eben auch teilweise mal auf die Chancen einzulassen und gucken,
wie man die Chancen gut regulieren kann oder gestalten kann und die Risiken
regulieren kann, wie das eigentlich bei allen Technologien ist.
Aber es ist schwierig und vor allem sehen wir uns natürlich auch einem anderen
Problem gegenüber, was related ist, was so Überwachungstechnologien betrifft.
Das war ja schon immer so ein Thema, ist im Prinzip ja auch vom,
ich würde fast sagen, fast mit einem Problem.
Einer der Gründungsthemen des CCC gewesen damals, Anfang der 80er Jahre.
1981 gab es das Tuwatt-Treffen und dort stand das ja im Prinzip schon auf der Agenda. Warum?
Weil man eben gesehen hat, dass es diese Wünsche zur Überwachung durch Technologie
immer gab. Das Einzige, was die Leute davon abgehalten hat, war, es war zu teuer.
So eine komplette permanente Videoüberwachung der Gesellschaft war, naja, nicht machbar.
Auch für die DDR, die das gerne getan hätte.
Also das scheiterte dann einfach an dem Geld und an der Verfügbarkeit von Technologie.
Aber in dem Moment, wo es eben machbar wird, dann sind die Begehrlichkeiten eben auch sofort da.
Und jetzt haben wir diese Geschichte und auch so dieses, ja man kann ja alle
Telefongespräche mitschneiden, aber das kann man ja sich gar nicht alles anhören.
Ja, aber genau das kannst du eben jetzt mit AI.
Du kannst dann auf einmal wirklich alles inhaltlich verfolgen und du kannst
alles auswerten und Ralf hat ja in der letzten Freakshow mal das Transkript
der vorletzten Sendung durchrasseln lassen und AI hat dann mal analysiert,
wer denn hier inhaltlich zur Sendung beiträgt.
Zu wie viel Prozent und wie das alles zu bewerten ist und worum ging es denn
eigentlich und was für Schwerpunkte wurden denn gesetzt.
Und wer braucht nächstes Mal nicht mehr kommen, oder?
Ja, also ich habe irgendwie nur 85 Prozent bekommen irgendwie und Ralf wurde
mit 90 und Rolf mit 95 Prozent bewertet.
Gut, aber die KI hatte der Ralf jetzt ja auch ausgewählt.
Ja, und sich dann strategisch nur auf Platz 3 gesetzt, damit es nicht aufhört.
Was ich sagen will ist, man kennt das, weil dafür sind die Systeme gebaut.
Zusammenfassung, das ist das, was wirklich relativ gut funktioniert.
Man muss nicht alles glauben, was dabei rauskommt, aber wer das einfach mal
mit eigenen Texten, Artikeln und so weiter überprüft, wird schnell feststellen, muss schon.
Aber wer das hier mit LMP wird das nicht gemacht, Kinder. Das ist ja wohl klar.
Keine, nein. Dann kommt's raus, Linus. Wer nämlich hier wirklich der Treiber dieser Sendung ist.
Linus Neumann, Podcast mal erst.
Der, ähm, die, ähm,
Diese Überwachungsmacht, auf die du ja mit diesen Technologien zu sprechen kommst,
auch da zeigt sich aber wieder, wie das menschliche Gehirn im Prinzip damit nicht umgeht.
Stasi war ganz schlimm, da hat mich einer beobachtet.
Aber wenn mich jetzt hier eine KI überwacht, ja, komm, das ist doch nur eine
Maschine, die intelligenter ist als ich.
Was sollte da schief gehen? Stell dir vor, aber wenn das mein dummer Nachbar
macht, das ist ein Problem.
Also menschlich, wenn das, also wir erlauben, wir sind ja jetzt schon dabei,
dass wir quasi eine Überwachung als weniger dramatisch empfinden,
wenn sie maschinell stattfindet.
Das war ja schon, ist ja schon seit vielen Jahren, das merkst du in dieser Chat,
Kontrolldebatte natürlich auch sehr gut.
Ja gut, dann liest da eine AI halt mit.
Ja, die erzählt das aber wenigstens nicht meiner Mutter.
Und das ist auch faszinierend, weil es mit Sicherheit, es ist ja völlig offensichtlich,
dass eine Computer- oder AI-gestützte Überwachung massiv mächtiger ist.
Viel, viel mächtiger als irgendwelche Stasi, IM, so und so, schreibt Freitagabends
einen Bericht an irgendjemand anders, der den dann in den Aktenkoffer legt oder sowas.
Was ja völlig egal eigentlich ist.
Außer, dass derjenige da natürlich irgendwas reinschreiben muss,
damit du ans Messer geliefert wirst, damit er da seinen IM-Posten behält und
nicht selber ans Messer geliefert wird.
Das sind immer ein bisschen, da kommen nochmal Details, ja, aber der Durchdringungsgrad
der Überwachung ist einfach so krank, krasser und wir nehmen das als Menschen nicht so wahr.
Ja.
Ja, naja, also.
Aber du kannst gut mit AI programmieren, du willst doch schon mal etwas.
Ja, das funktioniert in der Tat sehr gut.
Hast du schon irgendein Überwachungssystem vorgelegt?
Ich darf da nicht drüber reden. Ich bin nicht befugt, darüber Auskunft zu geben.
Ja, Leute. Das waren mal so ein paar Gedanken zu den Themen des Jahres,
die uns hier so primär auf der Meta-Ebene beschäftigt haben.
Wir wollen jetzt keine Angst machen, nur so ein bisschen Food for Thought mitgeben.
Das war eigentlich so ein bisschen unser Gedanke.
Und ich würde mich auch gerne und du sicherlich auch einfach auch nochmal bei
euch allen bedanken für die Begleitung in diesem Jahr.
Doch. Na gut.
Weil wir gerade jetzt zu den Live Event, also MP500, das war natürlich sehr
schön zu sehen, wer da alles kam und auch wie die Stimmung,
im Saal war, wie intensiv,
viele von euch uns hier zuhören und begleiten und mitdenken.
Das fällt mir immer wieder auf, wenn ich so Feedback erhalte,
dass wir da auch offensichtlich was,
stimulieren, dass wir da sozusagen zum Gespräch anregen und das zeigt sich in
den Reaktionen, in den Kommentaren,
Informationen, die uns immer wieder zugeführt werden und dem guten Gefühl,
was das auch bei mir auf jeden Fall erzeugt.
Ich schätze das sehr und finde das ganz toll und freue mich darauf,
das auch im nächsten Jahr fortsetzen zu können.
Dem kann ich mich nur anschließen. Ich habe gerade ja schon zu Beginn meine
Freude auch darüber zum Ausdruck gebracht, was wir dann trotz allen Herausforderungen,
die es jetzt in diesem Jahr gab,
geschafft haben, auch zu bieten.
In Form von Leuten, die mitgemacht haben, die weitere coole Perspektiven eingebracht haben.
Und wenn wir auch heute gerade noch nicht, also wir sind der Lösung ja nah für alle Probleme.
Ja, wir müssen nur noch zwei, drei Sendungen, dann hat sich das rauskristallisiert,
wie wir das dann angehen werden.
Wenn wir heute noch nicht die beste Lösung zu Ende ausformulieren konnten,
bin ich mir sehr sicher, dass sie von einer positiven Grundhaltung geprägt sein wird, zwangsläufig.
Der Weg nach vorne ist da, wo man eine positive Perspektive hat,
wo man mit Humor auf die Sachen zugeht und wo man sich,
wo man eine Offenheit hat für Neues und Andere alles andere ist auf jeden Fall
der Holzweg er ist es und sei es nur weil man selber.
Unzufrieden wird diese ganze Klasse,
Angst und Hass und Miesepetrigkeit und so, das ist auf jeden Fall die falsche Energie,
das ist auf jeden Fall der falsche Weg und man muss sich dazu auch zwingen und
man muss sich auch manchmal einfach….
Selber zwingen, sich nicht so ernst zu nehmen, die eigenen Dinge nicht so ernst
zu nehmen, den Humor und den Augenzwinkern zu behalten und das sind diejenigen, die am Ende,
selbst wenn wir morgen in drei Folgen noch nicht die Lösung haben,
werden wir ihr näher sein.
Und schlechte Zeiten überlebt man auch nur durch Humor und Freude und das ist
auch eine bewusste Entscheidung das zu tun und da muss auch ich,
der hier in der Sendung sehr häufig,
wenn Feedback kommen, wie schaffst du das die gute Laune zu behalten, schaff ich nicht,
ich schaff genau dieses eine Stunde Sendung,
Nee, aber das ist eine bewusste das ist eine,
eine bewusste Entscheidung, die man treffen muss für sich selber und die man
sich auch in Erinnerung rufen muss,
dass man mit einer positiven Grundhaltung an die Dinge geht und dass man über
Scheiße lacht und auch wenn richtig harte Dinge passieren dass man niemals irgendwie die,
Hoffnung aufgibt und niemals irgendwie in den Hass verfällt.
Hilft doch bei euren Wahlentscheidungen. Guckt einfach mal, wer in der Lage
ist, mit Humor aufzutreten.
Also die Humorbefreiten sind meistens die größten Probleme.
Naja, also ich finde, Christian Lindner ist ja inzwischen einfach nur noch ein Witz. Ja, aber,
Witz ist ja eigentlich Humor. Aber das ist auch schwierig.
Dann habe ich letztens, George Carlin heißt der glaube ich, das ist ein sehr
bitterer Stand-up-Comedian aus den USA, ich glaube der ist schon mindestens 10 Jahre tot oder so.
George Carlin ist 2008 gestorben, aber kann man sich immer wieder mal anschauen.
Es lohnt sich, den anzuschauen, weil der auch einen Finger in die Wunde legt.
Und da hat er irgendwie über Politiker gesagt, vielleicht sind das einfach,
wenn ihr alle sagt, die Politiker sind scheiße, vielleicht sind das die Besten,
die wir herbringen, die wir als Gesellschaft hervorbringen, weil wir selber scheiße sind.
Vielleicht sollten wir einfach mal anfangen nicht mehr scheiße zu sein dann
können wir irgendwann auch mal den Politikern vorwerfen, dass sie immer noch
scheiße sind und das finde ich Du.
Meinst Christian Lindner ist die Strafe für unsere eigene Doofheit?
Christian Lindner ist die Strafe für unsere eigene Doofheit ja das ist der beste
Christian Lindner, den wir verdient haben Ja.
Na gut. Leute, damit seid ihr dann ins nächste Jahr entlassen.
Wenn ihr uns auf dem Kongress seht, dann sagt man hallo.
Und wir hören uns dann nächstes Jahr wieder.
Auch für uns neuen Herausforderungen, wie wir diese Sendung Ja.
Du bist mal weg.
Ja, wir müssen schauen, wie wir uns da die Klinke in die Hand geben.
Remote, remote. Remote, meine Freunde.
Mit Datenfernübertragung.
Datenfernübertragung werden wir machen.
Was ganz Neues. Demnächst unter Ihrem Weihnachtsbaum.
So, das war's. Wir sagen Tschüss und bis bald.
Kommt gut. Übersteht Weihnachten. Streitet euch nicht, Kinder.
Zumindest nicht so lange.
Schlaft beim Kongress. Zwei Stunden schlafen, fünfmal duschen,
einmal essen. Kennt ihr.
Und dann neues Jahr.
Neues Glück.
Ja, oder alte, nochmal. Kriegen wir schon hin? Kriegen wir schon hin?
So, tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.